este domingo comienza a decatar el
primer mundial en tierras árabes mundial
que es del mismo comienzo de su
atribución pues ha sido marcado por la
polémica ahora muchas cuestiones muchos
cuestionamientos sobre los derechos
humanos sobre las condiciones laborales
de todos los obreros que sirvieron que
estuvieron aquí trabajando para las
infraestructuras de este mundial Y por
supuesto un mundial poco respetuoso para
el medio ambiente según muchos con estos
ocho estadios que de hecho pues tendrán
aire acondicionado pero sea como sea
pues acatar además también se le achaca
no ser un país con tradicional de fútbol
y sin embargo es un orgullo no solamente
para la gente de este país sino en
realidad para todos los árabes el ser
anfitriones de este mundial en cuanto al
ambiente ha venido creciendo poco a poco
sobre todo con la llegada de los hinchas
de los diferentes países hemos visto
hinchas de Brasil de Argentina de
Ecuador por supuesto los hinchas de la
triqui que se espera estén mañana en el
estadio albite que puede tener una
capacidad de unos 60.000 espectadores y
mucha también expectativa en cuanto a la
ceremonia inaugural por ahora mantenida
completamente en el secreto pero si se
sabe que catar quiere dejar huella con
esta ceremonia mostrándose como un país
abierto al mundo y multicultural